[Music]
hi my name is cece bell and the
character of el deafo is based on me
started out
just a dream
or a distance i was born with hearing
and everything was hunky-dory and then
when i was about four and a half i got
very sick with meningitis i ended up
losing about 85 to 90 of my hearing
so my parents decided that
the best way forward was to focus on lip
reading and for me to get hearing aids
this is the box that contains my phonic
ear heavier than it looks a couple of
ear pieces on and off switches the
t-shirt is microphone she sure would put
it around her neck and wear it all day
i always kept it covered and
i lied about what it was i was so
self-conscious about my hearing loss
that i did not want to learn sign
language are you deaf
i did not want to draw attention to
myself being different and feeling
different can be really challenging it
can be lonely
and if you're shy like i was and not
able to talk about it it's harder to get
out of those feelings
about five or six years ago
i published a graphic novel called el
deafo
which is the story of my childhood that
book has been turned into a television
show on apple tv plus
[Music]
i loved the
shows about superheroes that came on in
the early 70s they seemed like normal
people who were just putting on a
costume they weren't all muscular it was
the equipment that really captivated me
because being able to have all these
tools to do super heroic things really
reminded me of stephonic ear that i was
strapping on every day
and when i thought about the phonic year
as oh this is equipment and it does give
me a super power and the superpower is
super hearing i really like the idea of
turning that into an actual
superheroes
[Music]
you can call me
al daffo
it's just a stronger version of me but
in this case wearing a cape and wearing
an undershirt with a big old hearing aid
on top because that's the equipment that
is my superhero equipment what's really
important about that costume is
she is willing to
show that funny ear in real life and
that's what makes her really a superhero
[Music]
this is my own unique personal story
it's not the story of every deaf person
at all
[Applause]
[Music]
some people
might be like me and
wear hearing aids and lip read some
might prefer sign language the attitude
that i had as a kid is not my attitude
at all today sign language is an amazing
necessary vital language and there's
absolutely no right or wrong way for a
person with a disability to do their
disability
[Music]
i was a kid with all of the same
hopes and dreams and fears and desire
for friendship every kid has something
about them that makes them feel
different or self-conscious
you may feel that these differences just
will mark you for life and the truth is
those are the things that will make you
so much stronger look for the superhero
within
[Music]
you